[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hiv-1 genotyping targeting
integrase perspectives on surveillance
of anti-retroviral drug resistance i am
marie stone of labyrinths and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
h-i-v-d-r
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions we
ask that you participate in poll
questions during the presentation and a
survey at the bottom left of your screen
to submit your answers click on the
answer that is most accurate for you
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr kim stegen senior medical scientist
charlotte mckay johannesburg academic
hospital johannesburg south africa
dr natasha wood co-founder and chief
science officer hyrax biosciences
cape town south africa
and dr steve williams r d leader
capillary electrophoresis
thermo fisher scientific south san
francisco california
dr stegen you may now begin your
presentation
i would like to thank them fisher for
giving me the opportunity to present on
this webinar and i will be talking true
to the global status of hiv drug
resistance
by 2020
about 37.7 million people were estimated
to be living with hiv
including 20.6 million people from
eastern and southern africa which
represents the majority of the epidemic
and the retroviral rollout has started
in 2000 and by 2020 about 27 million
people were on aot which is a
three-fold increase since 2010.
the massive roll-out of anti-retroviral
treatment has also significantly has an
impact on the decline of aids-related
deaths
in 2016 the un set up some
goals in order to have as many people
living with hiv to know their status
of those that are knowing that know
their status to be on treatment and of
those that are on treatment the majority
being virally suppressed
although those targets were not met by
the end of 2020 we were not far off
84 of people
living with hiv know nodostatus
of those that know that are hiv positive
87 are on treatment and of those that
are on treatment 90 are variologically
suppressed
hiv is a virus that has a very high
genetic diversity this diversity is
driven by the production of 1 to 10
billion virus particles per day and in
addition to the reverse transcription
process being prone to error
reverse transcriptase enzyme does not
have a proof reading mechanism to
correct for the mistakes and therefore
we expect about one random mutation per
new pro-virus
the higher the levels of viral
replications the greater the risk for
the development of drug resistance as
more replication means more mistakes are
being made
virological suppression is not only
important to reduce the risk of
transmission but also to reduce the risk
of resistance therefore we need
efficacious interest treatments
when we look for efficacious
antiretroviral treatments we look for
drugs that have a very high viral
potency have a very high genetic barrier
to resistance and in addition good
safety profiles limited drug drug
interactions and the possibility of
co-formulation between different drugs
increase the appearance in patients and
therefore increases the risk sorry
increases viral suppression
in this figure the hiv life cycle is
represented with the different steps in
the life cycle and it's indicated which
different classes inhibit the different
steps in the life cycle
the most commonly used
drug clauses are those that inhibit the
reverse transcriptase step including the
nrti and the nnrci
drugs
as well as the protease inhibitors and
more recently the integrase inhibitors
have been included as well
initially the integrated inhibitors were
mainly focused in resource limited
settings to treat
to treat patients on turbine treatments
whereas with the
introduction of dog utegravir there has
been a shift of using integrated
inhibitors in first line treatments
however even though
some of the newer drugs have a very high
um genetic barrier and are very good
drugs all available drugs including the
newer classes are at risk of becoming
partially or fully inactive due to the
emergence of drug resistant virus
hiv drug resistance can reduce the
effectiveness of antiretroviral
treatment not only on an individual
patient level but in a in a global
perspective as well
therefore it is important to monitor hiv
drug resistance especially in regions
where hiv drug resistance testing is not
available at patient level
the outcome of these surveillance
efforts can then inform public health
treatment guidelines
we would now like to
participate in the first poll for this
webinar
so our first poll question is do you
perform hiv drug resistance surveillance
testing in your laboratory today
the options are yes
no but we are planning to add it to our
test menu offering
or no
please click on your selection to record
your answer
and i'll give you a short time to make
your selection
and i'll turn it back to dr stegen
thank you for your participation in the
poll
the world health organization has set up
an hiv drug resistance strategy
and they report on a regular basis on
the outcomes of countries that have
performed um drug resistant surveillance
so in the next couple of slides i will
touch on a couple of the results that
were published in the most recent 2021
drug resistance reports
there are four main pillars in the drug
resistance strategy from who the first
one is focusing on pre-treatment drug
resistance in adults initiating or
re-initiating first-line treatments
the second one is pre-treatment drug
resistance and ait naive infants who are
newly diagnosed with hiv
number three is acquired drug resistance
in adults children and adolescents and
finally surveillance of patients who are
on pre-exposure prophylaxis who are
diagnosed with hiv
i will discuss some of the results for
the first three pillars i will however
not touch on results from the last
pillar
starting with pre-treatment drug
resistance in adults initiating or
re-initiating first-line treatments
20 when 21 out of 30 surveys reports its
first generation nrti pre-treatment drug
resistance levels above 10
this is indicated on the graph on the
right with the vertical red line which
indicates the 10 percent cutoff all
countries that reported
less than 10
do have dots on the right hand side of
the bar
so you can see that nnrtir drug
resistance is
quite significant in most countries
in patients initiating or re-initiating
treatments
overall the prevalence of
first-generation nnrci pre-treatment
drug resistance was three times higher
among people reporting previous arc
exposure being on average 24
compared to those who are air truly airt
naif being 7
the prevalence of pre-treatment drug
resistance overall is still driven by
nnrci resistance which is indicated in
the red box
on the other hand nrci resistance in the
amber box remains relatively low
and if we look at
pi pre-treatment drug resistance is even
lower
as for the same with second generation
integrates
resistance
based on these results there has been a
change in many treatment guidelines
including the who guidelines where the
preferred first sign treatment regimen
has been changed from an nnrci based
regimen to now a combination of
xenophobia 3tc and doliategravir which
is offered in a fixed dose combination
also referred to as tld
moving on to pre-treatment drug
resistance in airt naive infants who are
newly diagnosed with hiv
were surveys conducted between 2012 and
2020 in about 10 countries
and
nnrti resistance was observed in over 70
in some of the countries
overall across all the countries at
least half of the kids
born
hiv positive had at least one drug
resistance mutation
although the level of nrcr resistance
was a bit lower um
it still exceeded above 10 in most of
the surveys conducted meaning that there
is quite a bit of transmitted resistance
between mom and child
based on these guidelines sorry based on
these results the guidelines have
changed once again and whereby who
initially recommended a pi based regimen
moving on from an nnrci based regimen
but now with the introduction of
dogutegraphy the preferred regimen is
actually a dogetech-based regimen
finally moving on to the acquired drug
resistance in adults children and
adolescents so this is when surveys are
being done in patients that are
on treatment that are failing at the
time of resistance testing and surveys
are usually conducted at 12
and then at 24 months of treatment
in this graph it is obvious that
most patients failing first-line and an
rti based treatment have a very high
prevalence of resistance in some
countries over 90 percent
when we look at surveys done at
patients that have been on treatment for
48 months the level of resistance drops
drops slightly but there is still a very
common presence of resistance in these
patients
so based on these results it is once
again obvious that nrti-based ait has a
very low genetic barrier to resistance
meaning that many patients failing these
regimens present with with drug
resistance
therefore the second line treatment
guidelines have now been changed for
adults currently failing non-dtg based
rt they should be switched to a dtg
based regimen with an optimized nnrci
backbone and in addition
adults that are currently failing a
first line dtg based regimen they should
be switched to a boosted pi based
richmond
among the surveys that were conducted
and that were reported in the who report
only 10 out of 34 35 countries included
integrates resistance surveillance
in these surveys less than 0.4 of drug
resistance was detected with it which is
extremely low we do however need to take
into account that the rollout of dtg
on
um so it is very common that we don't
see a lot of resistance therefore who
recommends to include nc resistance
testing for all new surveillance
activities going forward
switching gears a little bit now so
we're now no longer talking about the
who reports but because there's so
little limited information available on
integrates resistance um i thought it
would be informative to also look at
what is happening in the western world
um in this study in the us they looked
at 28 jurisdictions between 2014 and
2018
included more than 50 000 people of
which almost 20 percent had at least one
drug resistance mutation
despite that the rollout of integrase
inhibitors have been much longer
compared to low and middle income
countries they still only see a 0.8
percent prevalence of integrase
resistance and the resistance in
pre-treatment patients is still driven
by nnici resistance
in a recent review
they looked at acquired resistance of
patients failing dtg based treatments
and they found that the risk factors for
dtg resistance were mainly poor
treatment adherence drug interactions
and hiv disease factors such as high
baseline viral loads and active
opportunistic infections
in the review they only included 15
reported cases of dollar takeover
resistance because dollar taker
resistance is so rare of those 15 10 had
either sub-optimal dtg levels or poor
adherence
three patients had advanced hiv and
severe active infections
and four treatment naive and five
treatment experienced people had a
baseline viral load of over a hundred
thousand copies
there is however a concern that the
limited access of viral load and
genotypic testing in low and middle
income countries may influence the
proportion of
people with virological failure and
therefore the emergence of integrase
resistance
in canada a surveillance was done
between 2009 and 2016 including close to
10 000 individuals and they
found that the level of protease and
reverse transcriptase resistance
decreased significantly from 337 cases
per thousand preset individuals in 2009
to 285 per thousand treated individuals
in 2016.
on the other hand the integrase
resistance increased significantly but
remained very low it went from one per
thousand treated individuals in 2009 up
to seven per thousand treats individuals
in 2016.
of the 64 individuals that were newly
identified as having integrase
resistance the majority of them were
driven by exposure to roltegravir which
is the first generation integrates
drug
whereas there were only three cases of
new integrase resistance mutations for
dtg treatments
so to date most surveillance efforts
were focused on the protease and reverse
transcriptase gene
but with the massive roll out of dolya
tegavir and possibly other integrase
inhibitors who recommends to include
integrated resistance in any new
surveillance activities
in conclusion hiv drug resistance
surveillance has informed policy makers
on the best treatment regimens in
certain populations especially in
regions where a public health approach
is required
as countries scale up the transition to
integrate based into retroviral
treatment surveillance of the integrase
gene especially in low and middle-income
countries is required
this was the end of my presentation and
i invite you to participate in the next
poll thank you for your attention
for our second poll
the question is for what applications
does your laboratory perform hiv-1
genotyping please select all that apply
your options are clinical therapeutic
management
epidemiologic and or genetic
surveillance
or we do not perform hiv-1 genotyping
today in our laboratory
again remember to click on your answer
you may select more than one for this
poll question
and next we will be hearing from dr wood
thank you very much dr stegen for the
informative presentation and hi everyone
thank you for joining
um as i've been introduced my name is
natasha and i'm from hyrex biosciences
which is a company that develops develop
software for dna sequence analysis and
today specifically i'll be talking to
you about our x-pipe sanger hiv product
which is a platform for hiv drug
resistance analysis and surveillance
monitoring
so just as a presentation overview i'll
first provide you with a brief
introduction of the x-pipe workflow i'll
then jump into a series of screenshots
to show you exactly how x-type works and
then finally i will conclude
on how thermo-fisher and higher-expired
sciences are supporting this global
drive for um increased surveillance
so
as i've said exotype is exerciser is an
automated as an online platform
which you can access at the url at the
top left
and it is an automated hiv drug
resistance reporting platform for
standard sequencing data
and to place it more in the context of
hiv genotyping if you think of hiv
genotyping as a three-step process the
first step is to
do sample prep where you extract your
dna or rna the second step is the
sequencing where you generate your your
data and the final step here is the
analysis we actually do the
interpretation and the the analysis of
the data and this is where exact comes
in
and we really think about exatype as an
out of the box solution which
consolidates the global best practices
for um hiv stanger uh data analysis
specifically for hiv so what exercise
does is base calling and editing
it does contains the sequence generation
quality control analysis
drug resistance reporting for
surveillance
the results are available for download
in multiple formats
and you can share your results between
peers within an organization
and if you're wondering what the
underlying programs and software are
that power exotype
we've really consolidated the global
pest based practices so on the left over
here you can see your ab1 files which
come from the sequencing instrument
and in the next image
we have licensed the
university of british columbia's recall
software to do chromatogram editing and
review so when you see this online on
the user interface you are actually
using the recall software which you may
be familiar with
then finally on on the next
image the stanford hiv drag resistance
database we have implemented this
algorithm in our software as well
and just to note on this when stanford
updates the drug resistance database and
the drug calls and
resistance scoring
we update it on our side within 48 hours
so you're always running the most
up-to-date
software on exotype
and then finally on the right you can
see that you get your drug resistance
reports and drug calls for surveillance
and research and we also provide these
quality control and surveillance
monitoring results which have been laid
out by the who in
this document shown over here which
consolidates all of these best practices
so that's in a nutshell is an
introduction to exotype and i'll now
take you through a series of screenshots
so once you have logged in and created
an account you will access the dashboard
over here
to run your data you create a new job or
a new analysis and you go through a
series of steps over here i've shown you
the first step which is just to create
the job and and you can see at the
bottom left you need to select if you're
running the hiv juno typing kits with
integrase or with us integrase um and
these are provided by thermofisher
so once you've gone through the series
of steps which you can see in the tabs
on on the top so job details select
author all the way to review and submit
which is the final step once you click
this you will then be taken to a results
page or a preview results page and here
you can see on the left
in orange you've got all the samples
that you've uploaded and for each of
these samples you then have an
associated chromatogram file
um for each sample
if you've run both protease and reverse
transcriptase as well as integrase you
will have a separate chromatogram for
each of these gene regions
and as you are more familiar with and i
am i'm sure you will be able to do your
chromatogram editing and review for each
of these gene regions and each sample
once you've completed these steps
you will then have your results
and the results include a quality
control overview and over here you can
see the results of the sequencing
control analysis
you also then have sample specific
results which include the sample
warnings as well as drug calls and drug
scores for surveillance and then finally
you have a series of downloads that are
available for downstream analysis which
include
your consensus sequences in different
formats as well as a detailed summary
file which is a tab separated file that
you can open in excel and this file is
particularly useful for
[Music]
your surveillance large-scale
surveillance studies
i know i've just shown you a few
screenshots here but i would like to
encourage you to please get in touch if
you would like a demo or a training
session and you can get in touch at
sanger
at hirexbio.com
so please don't hesitate to get in touch
for a more in-depth uh overview
and then just to tie it back into the
surveillance studies
uh there are several indicators for
surveillance studies and one of these
are the sequence similarities
so if two viral sequences are too
similar to one another this may indicate
specific transmission chains
so reporting on sequence similarity is
very important to to monitor your
transmission dynamics
to show you how exotic does this
in the right-hand side image over here
you can see in orange that four samples
have been flagged um
as too similar to one another so
d8d69 and d12
are too similar to one another they're
too few differences between their
nucleotides
and if you then practice on a
phylogenetic tree you can see that these
four samples cluster on a single branch
which indicates that they
may have
been transmitted as a cluster
so before i hand over to dr williams who
will take you through the sample prep
and the sequencing steps i'd just like
to conclude that as hiv genotyping
scales across the world these kinds of
streamliners streamlined laboratory
methods and sequence analysis tools are
really key to facilitate the ongoing
surveillance of drug resistance
mutations and this is especially in
light of dr stegen's presentation
which presented the wh o drug resistance
report and it highlights the challenges
of implementing these national
surveillance plans
and then finally again i would just like
to encourage you to get in touch for a
demo or a training session if you are
interested and thank you very much for
your attention
hi thanks for joining me today i'm steve
williams i lead the assay development
group within the clinical testing
solutions business of thermo fisher
scientific
and today i'd like to describe the
design and the performance of the
applied biosystems hiv-1 genotyping kit
with integrase
and that is able to detect hiv drug
resistance mutations relevant to the
most widely used drug classes across a
broad range of viral subtypes
as you may know summer fisher launched
the first iteration of this product the
hiv-1 genotyping kit in 2017
and it's been widely used to help survey
drug resistance for protease and reverse
transcriptase inhibitors in low to
middle income settings
the new genotyping kit that we're
introducing retains the same excellent
performance characteristics of the
original kit but adds additional
sequencing of a region of the integrase
gene as the use of the integrase
inhibitors expands in low to middle
income countries
so specifically the hiv-1 genotyping kit
with integrase detects resistance
mutations in protease reverse
transcriptase and integrase
it is a cost-effective solution and has
broad coverage of all of the hiv-1 group
m subtypes including the circulating
recombinant forms of the virus
and the kit is compatible with plasma
and dry blood spots sample specimens and
it has a scalable workflow that can
deliver a drug resistance result in
about 14 hours all the way from rna
extraction through
a drug resistance report and that
workflow represents less than three
hours of total hands-on time
the kit comes with pre-mixed reagents to
minimize the number of pipetting steps
and includes a number of controls um in
in case uh
the need for troubleshooting
um and the analysis of the sangra
sequencing trace uh reactions can be
performed on a series of different
genetic analyzers that represent
different throughput requirements and
then finally as natasha explained in the
previous slide
we have a
easy to use
software to interpret the sanger traces
and to identify the drug resistance
mutations
so the assay workflow is shown in this
slide beginning with the specimen
processing to extract the viral rna
after rna extraction
there is a
rtpcr step
to amplify the virus followed by a nest
second amplification step it's a nested
pcr reaction and then sanger sequencing
of the drug resistance regions and
interpretation of the sanger sequencing
traces is
performed
as mentioned previously the end-to-end
process takes about 14 hours with about
three hours of total hands-on time
the rna extraction can be performed
using the magmax viral pathogen kit from
thermofisher
although any extraction methyl method
yielding high quality rna is acceptable
the magmax protocol has been optimized
for both plasma and dbs samples
and the genotyping kit itself consists
of two different modules the first
module
is an amplification module that does rt
pcr followed by nested pcr
and the second module is the sequencing
module
importantly the first amplification step
can amplify
all three regions of the virus protease
reverse transcriptase and integrase in a
single step so there's no need to split
the extracted rna sample into two
different amplification reactions the
second nested amplification step does
require splitting the pcr reaction into
protease and rt nested pcr and also
integrase nested pcr
and then the second module in the kit
consists of all of the sequencing mixes
that are required to sequence the
amplicons prior to running capillary
electrophoresis to separate the sango
fragments
and call bases and then the final step
in the workflow is the assembly of the
individual sequences into a consensus
sequence by the exotype software
and calling of the presence of any drug
resistance mutations
it's drilling down in a little more
detail um the hiv-1 genotyping kit
amplifies the
protease reverse transcriptase and
integrase reagent regions
which can predict drug resistance for
nucleoside reverse central kryptos
inhibitors for non-nucleoside or
transcriptase inhibitors protease
inhibitors and integrase inhibitors
in the pr region codon 6 to 99 are
amplified in the rt region we amplify
codons 1 through 251
and in the integrase region
codons 1 through 288 are amplified
so the first step as i mentioned of the
amplification is a multiplex rt pcr
where both protease rt and integrase are
amplified
and this produces
two different fragments
which are further amplified in a nested
pcr protocol for protease and rt we
produce a 1.1 kilobase fragment and for
integrase it's a kilobit one kilobase
fragment
so following um following amplification
the success of the amplification is
confirmed by running a gel and looking
for a band of the correct size
at this point if the amplification is
successful you proceed on to the
sequencing step of the workflow
the sequence thing
is performed with
in the case of protease and rt six
different sequencing primers to cover
the entire length of the nested amplicon
these are three forward
sequencing primers and three reverse
primers
and in the case of integrase
four different sequencing parameters are
used to cover the amplicon lens two
forward primers and two reverse primers
the result of the sequencing is is that
for any given nucleotide in either of
the amplitons you have at least two x
coverage both a forward and a reverse
read for each nucleotide
and following sequences sequencing the
reads are assembled by the exotype
software and
the consensus sequence checked against
the stanford hiv drug resistance
database
so the performance of the hiv-1
genotyping kit was validated in
collaboration with the cdc in atlanta
with our colleagues
and as part of the validation the
performance was assessed according to
the who validation criteria where we
looked at subtype coverage
accuracy
amplification sensitivity precision and
reproducibility so briefly this
validation
procedure starts with either 200
microliters of plasma or one to two dry
blood spot samples
rna extraction is performed and then 10
microliters of
extracted rna is input into this
multiplex rt-pcr reaction to amplify the
three different drug resistance regions
of the virus
um the rt-pcr reaction as we've
discussed has split into two different
nested amplification steps one to
amplify protease and rt a second to
amplify integrase
and then finally the
nested amplicons of sequence by saying
or sequencing and run out on the ce
instrument
so to
demonstrate these broad subtypes
coverage um samples with known subtypes
were analyzed in both plasma and dbs
formats
and in a total of 139
in total 139 samples were analyzed that
was split between 39 clinical research
samples and 59 analytical samples the
clinical research samples came from
nigeria kenya and haiti and the
analytical samples were a mixture of
either external quality assessment
samples from from proficiency panels
provided by the cdc
viral isolates or cultured integrase
coins from stanford
and as you can see
there from the table in the slide there
was successful amplification seen across
all of the major group
hiv-1
subtypes including the crs and
recombinant subtypes as well
next we looked at the assay accuracy
so the accuracy was determined for both
plasma and dbs samples across a wide
range of viral load all the way from the
limit of detection of the assay up to
quite high viral loads in up to as high
as 10 to the six copies per ml
the accuracy was determined by comparing
data against reference sequences from
three different sources firstly for the
clinical samples
that we clinical research samples that
we looked at
the sample was compared against the
sequence data from the original
thermofisher protease rte kit
or in the case of the integrase region
against the viruseq integrase assay
for the proficiency samples that were
looked at um the consensus sequence from
the proficiency exercise was used as
ground truth and for the isolates data
from stanford university sequence data
from stanford's university was used
so the conclusion from the accuracy
study is that for both plasma and dbs
samples more than 90 percent of the
comparisons between the test result the
result run with the new hiv one
genotyping kit and the reference sample
were at least 98 percent identical so
very high concordance with the ground
truth in this case
um next we examined the
assay amplification
and
at the amplification sensitivity
and this was measured by the presence of
a band
on the gel for the nested pcr product
it was determined for two different
groups of plasma and dbs samples
the first group had a viral load of
greater than 5000 copies per ml
and the second group had a viral load
between 1 000 and 5 000 copies per
minute per ml and for the second group
this was considered at or close to the
lod of the assay for the plasma samples
we found that more than 90 percent of
the specimens and replicates were
positive when the viral load was between
a thousand and five thousand copies per
ml
and more than 95 percent of the samples
were positive i.e they produced a band
on the gel
um when the viral load was over 5000
copies per minute
for the dbs samples more than 85 percent
of the samples were positive when the
viral load was close or at the limit of
detection between a thousand and five
thousand copies per ml
and at the slightly higher viral loads
above five thousand copies per ml more
than ninety percent of the samples
produce the band on the gel
so good
assay sensitivity for both plasma and
dbs samples
we also looked at the assay precision
and reproducibility
for
again across a wide range of viral loads
all the way from in the case of the
precision study 5 000 copies per ml and
the case of the
reproducibility study 2 000 copies per
ml after quite high viral loads
for the precision studies three sample
replicas were extracted and tested
together by one laboratory scientist
and for the reproducibility studies
three plasma samples at different viral
loads were run with five replicas on
different days
by two lab scientists
and then pairwise comparisons of the
nucleotide level were performed um to
assess the reproducibility and precision
and in all cases the pairwise
comparisons of the nucleotide level
um were very very good greater than 99
across all of the viral loads
examined
so in conclusion uh the hiv-1 genotyping
kit with integrase meets all of the who
hiv dr ashley performance criteria for
surveillance
it has broad range of subtype coverage
for both plasma and dbs samples
has excellent specificity and the
sensitivity of a thousand copies per ml
for plasma samples and
2 000 copies per per ml for dbs samples
a range of different capillary
electrophoresis instruments can be used
depending on throughput needs to analyze
the sanger sequencing reactions and the
workflow enables the user to go from
sample specimen to called drug
resistance mutation in less than 14
hours with about three hours three hours
of total hands-on time and the kit is
configured with premix primers and all
of the kit components have relatively
long shelf life and of course the kit
receives dedicated support from summer
fisher scientific
and for more information on the
availability of the new kit
i encourage you to visit the website
at the address here
www.serverfisher.comhivdr
and you can sign up for information on
when this kit will be available
commercially
so with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and thank both our two
previous speakers for their
so at this point i'd like to transition
to a round table discussion so kim and
natasha thanks for joining me
um we'll take some questions and have
some general discussion about the uh
about the hiv genotyping kit so one of
the first questions that we have is
around the availability of the exotic
software and how that fits into the
overall product offering so maybe
natasha i can turn to you and get a
little bit more information about that
yes absolutely and thank you for the
question and sorry that we didn't make
it
explicitly clear during the presentation
so for anyone who purchases either of
the hiv genotyping kits available from
fomo fisher
um what you do when you sign up is you
send us a lot number or a purchase
number of that tip and we verify that
you are a thermofisher customer and what
happens is that you've got free access
to the to the x-pipe software so you can
run unlimited samples using experts
to do your hiv dr analysis at no cost
okay great thank you natasha for
clarifying that
um now one of the one of the interesting
topics for discussion here is around
what lessons you know might be learnt
from
drug surveillance programs you know in
the united states or in
europe and how you know we can apply the
lessons learned from those efforts to
um drug resistance
surveillance um in low to middle income
countries so kim i'm wondering if you
have a have a perspective on that
uh thank you steve for that question um
i think indeed we always need to learn
from what has happened in the past
and and the fact that though your
segregate has been rolled out for a
longer period of time in the western
world is definitely important to
consider
and
as i presented in in one of the slides
the the level of drug resistance for
integrated inhibitors once exposed to
dollar tega remains extremely low which
is a very good sign
however we do need to be a bit cautious
because the monitoring of
patients in the western world
using biological failure is more
frequent than what it is in low in
middle income countries
so we definitely need to
keep an eye on it and that's exactly why
surveillance is so important in these
low and middle income countries because
if patients are not monitored very
frequently there is a higher risk that
there is biological failure for an
extended period of time before it is
detected which then obviously increases
the risk for development of resistance
yeah i wonder i mean there is a sort of
a complexity in monitoring patients
in this setting as well
anything to add
regarding
the effectiveness of
being able to monitor patients in this
way are you referring to viral law
testing or drug resistance really drug
resistance surveillance and testing yes
um well if you compare it to the us for
example i don't know what the situation
is at the moment but patients might get
a viral load up to four times a year
whereas in resource limited settings
it's usually at the maximum one time a
year if they're doing well on treatment
meaning that a patient in a low income
country might actually be failing for up
to 12 months before the first detectable
viral load
is being confirmed
um which definitely increases the risk
for resistance
yes yes thank you natasha anything to
add around lessons learned from um
drug resistance surveillance
and testing in the u.s and europe
yeah just the the comments on on the
data availability and
the amount of information we have for
surveillance studies historically a lot
of the information has been for subtype
b because which is prevalent um in the
u.s and europe
whereas in lower and middle-income
countries it's it's mainly non-b
subtypes so it really would be
interesting to see um how dilutive
resistance
um
developed in in the low and
middle-income countries so that will be
an interesting measure to keep an eye on
for sure
great
one of the questions we had from the
audience was around the regulatory plans
for the
um for the genotyping kit
so as we as we discussed in the
presentations this is uh currently uh an
ruo product um intended for use in
surveillance activities um but i can um
let the audience know that we are
pursuing also
ibd status for this product
so that in addition to surveillance
activities
in the future the kit could also be used
for patient management
so that is something that is you know
actively being worked on and we'll
update on the regulatory status of the
product um in the not too distant future
um
i think you know covid um has
really
um changed quite significantly
the structure of
virus surveillance programs you know
around the globe as we continue to
monitor the evolution of the of the
cyrus cough ii virus
um and i know you know in africa that uh
who has actually
been working to scale off pathogen
surveillance
in response to covid and that they've
set up a network of labs in africa that
are able to produce much higher
quantities of sequencing data
than previously were possible but i'm
wondering you know uh are there some
other key learnings from the the rampant
surveillance
um and how this might have impact as a
result of covert and how this might have
impact on hiv-1 genotyping surveillance
efforts kim i'm wondering do you have
thoughts on that
um yes as much as covert has
taken over our lives in a negative way
in in many cases i think there are also
many positive lessons that can be
learned from this and i think there is
definitely an increased capability of
sequencing in general um for example on
the african continent and that is
largely driven by the need of doing
covet sequencing and once that
capability is there and the instruments
are there
there is skills skills development and
then it's not so difficult to switch
over from one organism to another
and the other point is definitely the
the sequence
data availability from covets all the
covert sequences are
immediately put in a global database and
if you look at the the whole drug
resistance report as important as the
information is many of the surveys are
quite outdated by the time these reports
come out and we're looking at data from
2015 2016 in the 2021 reports whereas
for covitz data is available within
weeks or within months so i think there
is definitely a possibility that also
for hiv these data could be become
available much more quickly and i think
that would definitely benefit the
surveillance efforts
yeah no totally agree natasha anything
to add there
yes yeah absolutely i think covert has
[Music]
done a lot to to improve surveillance
globally and and especially in terms of
the sharing of information and data
between countries and laboratories
and in some ways
it almost goes both ways um a lot of the
low and middle income countries have
been set up uh quite well for doing um
data aggregation because of hiv
but i think one of the the good things
about krovit is is almost the
standardization of data so so the the
mean the the way that we can compare
clover data has it's really phenomenal
and i think there's been a little bit of
a lack of that kind of standardization
for hiv and it would be great to see
um
like kim said just the access become
available so much sooner uh instead of
years and years after after the data
aggregation for hiv um and also
looking ahead you know in terms of
co-infection for for hiv patients as
well as uh covert infected patients it
will be fascinating to to be able to do
surveillance on this kind of current
action
okay yeah thanks for that
um now that's a couple of the of really
great things that have come out of covid
um in terms of improving you know
infrastructure and sequencing capability
um
what about you know maybe some of the
less than desirable impacts of covid in
terms of
um you know being
able to monitor hiv drug resistance um
is have we seen kim
some negative consequences um in terms
of the recent kobe pandemic
yeah i think in terms of the
surveillance efforts a lot of the
funding that was initially allocated for
hiv has been shifted to covet which
probably delays the current hiv
surveillance that was planned or was
ongoing and in addition more on a
patient level the heart lockdowns have
definitely
had a negative impact on the frequency
of viral load testing for example
patients were scared to go to healthcare
facilities and were therefore skipping
their their appointments
and in addition to that it has also had
a negative impact on treatment pickup
and if patients don't pick up their
pills then obviously they are
non-adherent meaning that they have a
higher risk of developing resistance
which we
will probably only see the impact of
this in in the next couple of months if
not years
because obviously resistance doesn't
develop overnight but if patients are
less adherent the risk definitely does
increase
um but with the infrequent monitoring we
will only find out later on which
patients are actually not doing so well
compared to others and so unfortunately
that has been a bit of a negative things
on the other hand some countries have
taken that as an opportunity to push
um for example dispensing um drugs for
six months instead of one month or two
months so that patients actually don't
have to go to clinics that often which i
think has in the hiv world has been um
an objective for a very long time but
it would work
and now
we were kind of forced to implement
these things and it and it seems to be
working um but again surveillance will
tell us later on um how this impact
actually has a further on impact on the
on the resistance overall
yeah yeah
um natasha from your perspective have
you seen
um any more negative impacts of uh
coping pandemic on capability to
monitor hiv drug resistance
uh yeah so just a quick comment on that
i guess is on
you know from outside we can see the
number of sequences that are being run
on a monthly basis so the statistics for
that uh substantially decreased it was
almost non-existent for about a year
um and that's both for
just uh the research limits and
resources so a lot of the laboratory
stuff were
reassigned to covert surveillance um
during 2020 so there was just a lot less
information so
we have started seeing a pickup now so
hopefully um
patients will be you know analyzed or
the data will be analyzed and and uh
you know the
efforts will
just be registered distributed a bit
better back to hiv as well
yeah
one of the questions that we had from
the audience was around the availability
of the kit
i think we tried to cover that in the
presentations but just for further
clarification
the launch of the
hiv-1 genotyping kit with integrates the
ruo
product is pending and i encourage
everybody to
visit the website
www.thermafisher.com backslash hiv dr um
to sign up for
updates on uh product launch and
availability so that is definitely your
best source of information with regards
to the availability of the product
um i want to turn um just briefly to
um different approaches to different
technologies that are in use for hiv
drug resistance
testing i think
you know in the in the us in particular
we have seen a trend uh towards ngs
technologies for drug resistance
monitoring and
um and i'm wondering um kim would you
mind offering up just a brief comparison
between ngs and sanker based approaches
in the lmic setting
yeah so um
it depends a bit what what the situation
in your lab is if you have a lot of
samples that come in in batches
then probably an ngs approach might be
more cost efficient and more time
efficient as well
however if you are performing drug
resistance testing on samples that come
in in small batches or like
two every day then a sanger sequencing
approach is probably
the better option in getting the samples
out in a in an
acceptable turnaround time if you want
um from a technical point of view i'm
i'm convinced that if
labs that are currently doing sanger
sequencing that's provided they can can
buy the equipment or get access to the
equipment um there is a relatively easy
switch over to next generation
sequencing and vice versa if next
generation sequencing is implemented
because of covet for example um the
similar skills are required for ngs and
for senger so i think going forward both
methodologies will will go hand in hand
and depending on the situation the one
might work better than the other
great yeah thank you natasha anything to
add uh ngs versus sanger in this setting
uh not really
what can i reiterate what kim said i
think in future they both have benefits
and uh labs will will get used to using
the one or the other depending on the
the samples and what they want to get
from it
yeah and you know i think it's it's
definitely true that you know with all
of the additional sequencing that's
going on
um as a result of covid um labs are
definitely better set up
um to act to perform both both
approaches at this point um from an
extraction and amplification standpoint
whether it's saying or whether it's ngs
there's been a general increase in
capability i think not just in lmic's
but across the globe in in terms of
being able to perform um sequencing um
so um i think at that point i'd like to
thank you you know both your
participation in this in this round
table and also for your excellent
presentations
um and perspective on
hiv drug resistance surveillance
and i'll hand it back to the moderator
for closing comments thank you
thanks steve
thank you
thank you again dr stegen dr wood and dr
williams for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you